[Music]
drew
come forward
a chef this is a chicken quiche with
cremini mushrooms baby spinach and feta
cheese
[Music]
unbelievable
[Music]
well drew i have a huge problem with
this dish
it's that you haven't made it for me
sooner
thank you chef because if you had drew
then i would know how good you are at
cooking food that's bad
i'm sorry chef and when i say bad i mean
michael jackson bad
thank you chef you know how he looked
really really bad at the end of his life
chef i'm sorry i don't know if you like
the dish or not
you don't know if i like the dish or not
well let's put it this way
pat your knives get out you're off the
show
[Music]
sorry chef because
you should be working in the finest
restaurant in the world
thank you chef just not any world that i
live in
sorry sir because frankly drew i'm
jealous of you
thank you sure and your ability to not
give a sh
about what you cook this
[Music]
is not fit for human consumption no
this should be eaten by a higher life
form
with a more complex palette but also an
altruistic drive to save humanity from
dishes like this joking not
you just have to die
so you won't have to endure a life in
which you will
never exceed what you have achieved here
[Music]
today
thank you chef
in conclusion
you